beh allora ragazzi mi volevo solo video
se la pavidea citati su servisse creato
mais ma si può per la macchina ma perché
mi sa che hanno cambiato il menu ma no
ma dai ma geniale quindi vedi che
comunque carro armato ce l'hai già di
fianco casa lance non c'è un motivo
globo allora ragazzi oggi volevo partire
molto carico senza fare la parte della
ricerca degli oggetti perché oggi ho
messo ho fatto partita direttamente
sopravvivenza perché oggi voglio provare
a giocare una partita seria quindi
canonica nel modo in cui gioca un pro
player di sixty seconds esistono i
problemi di siseco non hanno la ragazza
ma esistono poche se fai a modalità
sopravvissuti da più o meno tutto c'è
quello che dovresti avere strano chi
mangerà oggi nessuno perché faccio
mangiare la gente sono uscite che nella
porta bravi ragazzi bravi tutti con che
giocare sia il modo migliore per
rilassarsi anche io ma non lo farete
oggi
allora ragazzi la mia età oggi oggi
giochiamo insediamento sociale ci gioco
sempre seriamente ma oggi voglio
veramente vincere se non vinco cancello
questo video in sette giorni va bene
cioè mido questa penitenza se non vinco
va bene mary jane insiste nel dire che
siete incompleta senza il suo strumento
musicale perché sole mangiare guarda che
c'è lo sguardo di chi si vuole mangiare
lo strumento avremo lasciarle a dare
un'occhiata ai torva bene rilasciano da
chissenefrega cavoli suoi averi che c'è
il disegno del carro armato
chissenefrega vai vai vai vai pure vai
pure fi b g ne ha fatto i salti di gioia
quando abbiamo aver sentito la ricerca
ha detto che sono riusciti a trovarla si
accontenterà anche di altro un esempio
qualche spartito noi realtà speriamo che
la tuba non si sia salvata preferiamo
decisamente l'inter ferenze radio o il
dolce suono del silenzio backyard alla
radio parlano di lanci rifornimenti per
caso si può uscire fuori per la
un'occhiata certo è tornata a mary jane
è andato via il padre nostro torneo è
trovato la tuba la nostra maschera
antigas e stata danneggiata starebbe
sotto quella cassa prima ancora che
atterrasse stata una pessima idea
va bene abbiamo un sacco di jos ragazzi
abbiamo un sacco di bottiglie aveva un
sacco di toba raga siamo messi bene
se non facciamo cagate teoricamente
allora
giorno 5 ragazzi si preannuncia una
partita ottima e anche abbastanza lunga
propri terroso gli highlights e ora di
andare a portare provviste perché può
andare solo lui tra l'altro bol.it mi
valigia e provviste devi devi scannare
devi trovarne un miliardo di anni com'io
miliardo vai io non lo so timi non lo
mando mai fuori perché mi sembra tutto
mingherlino sono meno riuscì a portare
una sega però non si sa mai
stavamo finendo la nostra scena si può
definire tale quando abbiamo firma
infatti non vi ho dato niente da
mangiare mini che state mangiando nel
sentito bussare la porta sembra un
commerciante molto interessato a qualche
munizione che si fa li diamo la dama
perché non ho iniziali siano nella dama
invece riflettere noi gli abbiamo
offerto da daniela o po confuso tipo
appreso a spiegarci cosa fossero le
munizioni
noi abbiamo finto di non capire
divertente finché lui non è andato via
con il gioco farabutto sentito dei
rumori provengono dal basso e orali era
uno sguardo alla botola nell'angolo
quella che chiusa a chiave da quando
siamo scesi non lo puoi fare perché non
ho niente però va bene
in tutto questo mio figlio non è tornato
e loro non sta mangiando e bevendo da
una da una vita
ok mia figlia sta bene stavamo per
andare 2000 e cosa abbia sentito bussare
alla porta chi può essere a quest ora
come diamo la foto per sopravvivere
l'esplosione dovremmo aprirli certo io
sto cercando di fare tutto il contrario
di quello che farei di solito per vedere
che cosa succede chi era apri la bocca è
stato avventato sembra che ci abbia
fatto venire qualche brutta malattia la
tua se ci sta facendo impazzire timi
dovrebbe essere già tornato dobbiamo
prepararci al peggio potremmo non
rivederlo più è morto mi è morto timi
porco demoni aveva anche la valigia
chissenefrega di lui sta andando
malissimo e sta partita malissimo e la
partita prigione di dvd di sisti seconda
quando si xvi secolo diventa by papa
vediamo se riesce a trovare qualcosa di
decente non con la valigia giustamente
domani ragazzi diamo da mangiare a tutti
che sono è un po di tempo che non sta
facendo niente senza bere
a quanto pare abbiamo già un nostro
personale orto postapocalittico abbiamo
trovato degli strani funghi sono
abbastanza grandi per fare un bel
pranzetto e soci prepararsi un banchetto
a base di funghi ha voglia
sto facendo tutto l'opposto ragazzi di
quello che faccio di solito tutto o più
2 ok perfetto più 2 acqua p2 zuppa e la
valigia
abbiamo trovato una valigetta in pelle
così intatta va bene
ottimo quindi è quella che ha preso timi
la ritrovata al padre ottimo va bene è
tornato sano e salvo pesano secondo me
non è molto sano però almeno è salvo
allora dolores che porti niente la
valigetta non me la perdere non morire o
se muori porta la valigetta in casa e
poi muori
va bene ok no perché non è possibile che
ogni volta quando fare qualcuno mila
palmi per della valigia per domandare
un'altra recuperarla in casino mi è
morta mia figlia wat mary james
infiorate s'è infuriata quando ha saputo
che non che non sa che non le sarebbe
toccato neanche una goccia d'acqua
furibonda fuggita nella landa desolata
gridando che ce ne pentiremo giurando
che avrà quell'acqua in un modo o
nell'altro siamo terrorizzati tanto mia
figlia conto per quanto può valere ho
perso i miei figli tutto questo c'è il
gatto come rischiamo non ricordo child
of apple ci ha dato il gatto c'è un
gruppo di persone se non sembrano
partite amichevoli ci sembra di
conoscere alcuni una volta lasciano
parte del comitato di vigilanza del
nostro quartiere mazza ga vigilanza
dovremo fare qualcosa prima che sfondano
la botola pam e lucchetto
se non ci prendono tutto cioè mi
prendono tutto pacifismo cosa è successo
ho bloccato la botola funzionato non
credevamo che un piccolo lucchetto
potesse fermare invece si è rivelato
sufficiente a scoraggiare gli invasori
sconosciuti peccato per il lucchetto che
non è più utilizzabile va bene ancora un
giorno e poi gli dà un po da mangiare a
ted perché ho paura che siccome è malato
credo che abbiano più bisogno di cure
credo è non lo so chiunque abbia
progettato questo rifugio antiatomico
deve essere un genio non siamo sicuri
che quella roba verde che con a dal tubo
faccia parte dell'arredamento non pensa
neanche io
tienila anch'io voglio un bunker anti
atomico però dovrebbe essere bellissimo
ci sono degli insetti uno scarafaggio
mutar due scarafaggi
abbiamo scoperto che cheryl cole ha
trovato un nuovo giocattolo un pezzo di
cablaggio i no coke attirato fuori dal
muro
chissà cosa serve quel cavo ma le luci
sono ancora accese quindi non può essere
così importante no dovremmo togliere il
cavo al nostro amico plauso ispezionarlo
sì ma muoio perché non caos c'è
l'esplosivo prendo le lettere città
fortissimo cos'è che era il cavo porta
un vecchio camion arrugginito
parcheggiato sul vialetto d'accesso dei
nostri vicini hanno messo delle cimici
del nostro rifugio quando abbiamo
dormito quando dormivamo hanno ascoltato
tutto volo ci siamo detti era ci stavano
ascoltando per quale motivo gli agenti
che ci stavano spiando sono alla porta
appare vogliono darci spiegazioni
dovremmo ascoltare cosa ha da dirci va
bene di te mi è mai rubato tutto ci
hanno sventolato in faccia una sorta di
documento d'identità ci ha detto che
fanno parte di una missione governativa
segreta
l'ecdc non serviamo aspira in noi ma il
gatto sospettano che sia una spia
sovietica
beh più o meno o si allinea assicurato
il ciri contatteranno con ulteriori
dettagli ragazzi ci manca solo che shari
come sia una spia russa
intorno alle 3 di notte durante uno dei
suoi momenti di pazzia carico si è
schiantato di faccia contro il muro da
quel caduto mattoni instabile dietro
c'era una scatola di sì correct di
sigari con all'interno delle munizioni
io non so più che cosa dire sei
veramente un agente segreto scarico
incredibile se incredibile grazie a un
impianto di comunicazione altamente
tecnologico composto da bicchieri di
carta e chilometri di spago gli agenti
ci hanno telefonato per la c la prossima
missione segreta che presto ci
assicurerà un posto nel bunker dei vip
vogliono che portiamo a termine una
spedizione che scriviamo quello che
vedremo nel diario
facile come bere un bicchier d'acqua no
non so quanto volerlo mandare fuori
provvediamo
sono passati tre giorni sono tornato
vivo bene quindi se vai in missione da
solo ti fa scalare subito i giorni siamo
dovuti passare per quartieri erano
pericolosi anche i tempi migliori piena
di bande di cani e gatti mutanti
combattiamo tra di loro armati fino ai
denti va bene
ted si è ferito
bisognerebbe fare qualcosa per curare la
malattia di ted kennedy si è ferita come
se non bastasse 76 morse uno zombie
tornando dalla nostra ultima spedizione
abbiamo notato i segni su un muro in
rovina qua vicino
era una sorta di mappa della città con
un posto contrassegnato da una ics sarà
a riserva segreta di zuppa di qualcuno
verifichiamo ma guarda non ho bisogno di
zuppa perché sto abbastanza messo bene e
dvd di kit medici avrei bisogno quello
se dopo il successo dell'ultima missione
è evidente che siamo affidabili poiché
gli agenti sono tornati con un'altra
richiesta
dobbiamo essere generosi e fornire un
paio di barattoli di zuppa qualche
bottiglia d'acqua per un agente sul
campo
loro si occuperanno della consegna in
cambio ci daranno una bella pacca sulla
spalla e la promessa di un futuro
migliore in un rifugio governativo
sicuro gli dò tutto quello che ho giusto
per vedere dove andiamo a finire ragazzi
mai nemico finto chimico vinto
no no dagli agenti governativi delle
palle abbiamo accettato volentieri
soddisfare ci hanno ringraziato per aver
fatto il nostro dovere civico e hanno
preso che sarebbe ritornata e molto
riferite le ferite erano molto gravi non
sono state medicate purtroppo sono
infettate e tende non ce l'ha fatta
mamma mia ragazzi ho fatto tutto il
contrario di quello che volevo fare però
va bene siete morti sto gioco
impossibile allora è la nuova vera parti
scherzi secondo me ho fatto schifo però
nel senso è stato molto bello provare a
fare il contrario di quello che tu
vorresti fare di solito per me è un mini
sono finito ma le prove ciò vi giuro ho
provato è stato è un bell'esperimento
perché alla fine in genere io faccio
sapere cose sbagliate e quindi ho
provato a fare le cose
volutamente sbagliando e sono dorato di
più del solito quindi va bene allora vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi come semplice
ragionamento mi piace iscrivetevi al
canale spiaggia della campana nina co si
dimette aggiornatissimi nuovo video che
escono perché la campania e l'ice
schiacciate
la ragazzina è sacra e noi ci rivediamo
come sempre hanno un prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]